hi everyone i'm sad omar i'm the
director of the yale institute for
global health as many of you
are likely to know
i am delighted to welcome you to the
uh the first hybrid event that we have
started doing um
you know in this uh new academic year
uh that the yale institute for global
health has started doing
uh we are delighted to be here at the
yale school of public health and we
welcome
those who are
joining us online i know uh the bunch of
you
have been joining us
online over the last few years
so in addition to the yale institute for
global health today's event is a
co-sponsored by the walker fund at the
macmillan center at yale
the covet 19 pandemic has highlighted
the critical need
to better prepare for future pandemics
and this is not going to be the last
major infectious disease related event
we have already seen monkey pox
you know public health emergencies
pop up with some frequency and there are
estimates that that unfortunately the
frequency of these kinds of events
is uh likely to increase
during this event um our panelists will
present and discuss uh several themes uh
and several elements for an
effective pandemic response
and we have three very prominent
thoughtful
panelists and speakers for today's event
and
before moving to their presentation and
our discussion i'm going to introduce
them together
um give them give you a little bit of
their background and then we're going to
go to there's respective
presentations under the question and
answer session where i'll start with
questions and then we'll take audience
questions both on site and online
so
dr jennifer nuzzo is the
inaugural director
of the
pandemic center at brown university
school of public health before i became
the inaugural director of ygh i all you
i used to imagine that people just come
into the their centers on the on day one
and cut a ribbon or something that's why
that's how they become inaugural
directors i have no such illusion
anymore
but but the center has already done a
lot of significant things and has
is becoming
fairly prominent in the discourse around
public health preparedness she's also a
senior fellow for for global health at
the council
on foreign relations
she's an epidemiologist by training
her work focuses on global health
security
public health preparedness and response
and
i guess if i can sort of
share my bias most importantly on health
systems resilience so we are public
health people we go for
uh primary prevention if possible so uh
creating a resilient health system is in
that category
uh dr nuzu um regularly engages with
with the media both electronic and print
media to educate and inform about
emerging health security trends
dr wilmond james is a former member of
parliament
in south africa and ranking
opposition
spokesperson on health currently he's a
senior researcher scholar at the
institute for social and economic
research and policy at columbia
university just a small train line away
where he leads the center for pandemic
research
he conducts research on pandemic
response and biosecurity and convenes
with some frequency high level meetings
on planetary threats
he's also an honorary professor of
global health at university of
wits waters rand in johannesburg
beth cameron is is a professor of
practice of health services uh policy
and practice at bryant university and dr
cameron is a national expert in health
security uh pandemic preparedness
biosecurity biodefense
and bioterrorism
and she has
worked at the highest level of the
government
including serving as the special
assistant
to the president and and senior director
of for global health security and
biodefense for the white house national
security council
she also serves as a senior advisor to
the u.s agency
for international development usaid
but
here
is not representing any government or
government agency she is here as a
professor and as in her own personal
capacity as a key opinion leader in this
area so we are honored to have all three
of you here today
um
so
we uh
for today's event each of our panelists
will do a short presentation
followed by one or two questions
and so after the presentation is
complete
so actually i would suggest that you
restrict those questions to clarifying
questions and any substantive questions
we will get to them after uh the the
initial presentation so if you if you
want any clarification feel free to sort
of follow up but if you have uh you know
more substantive questions we'll do that
in the panel
um and obviously for those
on zoom will also have an opportunity to
ask questions
with that i would like to welcome dr
nuzo uh to deliver the presentation
[Applause]
thank you so much thanks for that kind
of introduction and thanks for the
invitation it's really such a pleasure
to be here
um to
learn more about the work of people i
admire so greatly like yourself son and
your colleagues but also to meet with
students we had a great conversation
today
so if we advance to the next slide
we're going to spend today talking about
how to
better prepare for these sorts of events
and that's a huge topic but i'm just
going to take two small pieces which is
thinking about surveillance and the role
of surveillance and how we can improve
it as well as the workforce
the workforce to support surveillance
but to some extent the the broader
public health workforce
prior to coming to brown while i was at
johns hopkins i had the privilege to be
part of the team behind the johns
hopkins coronavirus map which was
started by my hopkins colleague dr
lauren gardner and i'm showing a
screenshot of the map from actually
friday of last week
so these are somewhat up-to-date numbers
but i'm showing this really as a bit of
an allegory for how we should think
about improving surveillance and data
the first thing i want to point out is
that this map was created by people
outside of government because there was
nothing like it and there was very much
need to stay up to date with the case
numbers where they were occurring to
analyze those case numbers in the
context of other factors so that was
clearly a need that in my mind
there is now at least a mechanism to
address with the the creation of the who
pandemic hub but still i think a long
way to go to make sure that we have in
future events something like this this
was an extraordinary resource intensive
effort very expensive effort
i'm very proud of the work that it did
um but it also i think represented just
a small piece of of the challenge of
fixing surveillance for these sorts of
global emergencies
and part of why we need to fix this is
not just to get the up-to-date picture
the dashboard that tells us what what's
going on now and to help us analyze
these numbers so that we can understand
how best to target our resources
but we also need to understand the
context by which the data
that populate these sorts of dashboards
are generated and that's the real piece
that i don't think that we're spending
enough time trying to fix so if you
could advance to the next slide
i'm just going to show you a screenshot
from one day and actually this graph
doesn't appear on the dashboard anymore
but it used to and it was the daily case
numbers being reported each day across
the globe and as you can see from this
graph there's one day that's not like
the others there was one day and you can
imagine on that day when we got those
case numbers we thought what's going on
like this is an error
is something else happening what is
going on and it wasn't until you know
you kind of parse you look at the data
and you realize it's all coming from one
country and then you look in the news
and you realize what's happening which
is that this was a day where a single
country
decided to change its case definition
so one country's policy decisions can
greatly change our understanding
of how the pandemic is unfolding and
what it means for the global community
and the truth is we don't have the
standardized definitions so that all
countries are finding and reporting
cases in the same way so what we have
here is really a hodgepodge based on
what countries decide to do so this is
one of the challenges when we talk about
global surveillance which is how do we
actually get a meaningful common global
picture of what's happening
absent
standards for how we collect these data
how hard we look for these data and how
we report them
if you go to the next slide
this is further complicated so the case
definition one is probably an easier
problem to solve but what underpins our
abilities to find cases is a much harder
thing that we also need to invest in and
that's
how countries have different capacities
to go out and look for cases
this is a graph that's not up to date
but it was taken at a point in time
showing
test positivity from different countries
and as you can see there's a huge range
and there are some countries like
mexico's up here on the top that had
very high test positivity throughout the
entire duration of the pandemic and what
that meant
is that they were not doing a whole lot
of testing so the people who were
getting tested were the people who were
highly probable of having
um
the cyrus kobe 2 infection that causes
cobit 19.
so that means that
you know broad testing in the community
testing people who are asymptomatic
was largely not happening
and this is indeed true when you look at
different countries policies and
different countries practices you see a
wide range in terms of what countries
are doing one of the things we found in
looking at these data
was that many countries
were
largely throughout much of the pandemic
only testing travelers
because travelers paid for the tests
so what that meant is the positive test
results were largely coming from people
who were from outside the country
probably lower risk
because they're probably wealthy and
traveling
and not necessarily then reflective of
what was happening in country in terms
of transmission so if that's what we're
rolling up into our national
or our global surveillance picture then
we're not getting a real sense of what
is happening within countries so beware
when you see analyses that say this
country did better than this country
based on the data that these countries
reported
recognizing that the processes by which
those data are generated are very very
different
and
do not in any way conclude that
that capacities may not be relevant to
those analyses because capacities are
what countries use to not only go out
and diagnose cases but also to count
deaths and to determine cause of death
and if we want to get a standardized
picture we need to make sure we need to
level the playing field and make sure
all countries have the same capacities
and equal probability of finding cases
finding deaths determining cause of
deaths and being able to report them
next slide
so that's just a very brief snip on the
data side there's so much more i could
say about data improvements but i want
to save time for the discussion so i'll
just kind of pause there and then turn
to the workforce because i do think that
sometimes we spend a lot of time talking
about data as though it's an end point
as opposed to a tool
an
information input to a process that's
supposed to end with a public health
action taken to make people safer
and what is needed is not just a data
point a one and a zero that your
computer
generates but
people to gather the data to analyze the
data to act upon the data and then to
take you know to take action
uh depending on where the data points us
and there are many different types of
workforce that really i think are
essential for this work but i'll just
focus on one and i'll talk about the
epidemiology workforce so what i'm
showing here is a graph from the the 20
the most recent version of the global
health security index which we published
in the end of 2021 and this shows just a
snapshot of the epidemiologic workforce
as clearly you can see again lots of
heterogeneity across the globe in terms
of how many epidemiologists per capita
exist in countries and i think it really
speaks to the continued work to make
sure we develop train and retain the
epidemiologic workforce and i put some
emphasis on the retain part because i am
deeply worried about that going forward
i am deeply worried the united states is
colored in relatively dark compared to
other countries meaning we tend to have
more epidemiologists per capita as
compared to other countries but if
you've talked to anybody who's worked in
health public health departments you
have learned that there's been a
hemorrhaging
of qualified experienced public health
workers in part because they're burnt
out they feel um they feel threatened
they feel like there's a better career
path for them elsewhere and
this is likely not unique to the united
states we've seen this in many contexts
and so i think we really have to worry
about the sustainability of these
workforces and making sure we not only
train them but we also retain them
next slide
i do think though that it's not just
about training epidemiologists it's not
just training community health workers
which i frankly think is one area of
deep deficiency for which if we were
going to put efforts into any one place
it would in my view it would probably be
that and sold to your point about health
systems resilience i think that's one
key lesson from our work in health
systems resilience about the importance
and unmet needs in terms of shoring up
the community health workforce
but it's not just about the technical
skills
it's not just about putting people in
these positions
it's also about training them and
empowering them to make decisions and to
act upon the information that they have
at hand to say we need to do something
and here's what we need to do based on
my training based on my experiences
based on what i'm seeing in the data
again data are not the end point data
they're the start of the process the
information we use to act but what we
have seen is really
a lack of empowerment of a public health
workforce to be able to act and to be
able to act swiftly
such that we respond to events that
occur with the possibility that they
could be worse than they might seem
right now
and let me tell you seeing the monkey
pox
i'll just call it a debacle play out in
the united states on the heels of a
covid debacle where delays resulted in
costs to
threats to life
seeing that yet again play out in terms
of our response to monkey pox a virus
for which we had more tools and frankly
a better leg up than we did for kovid
i think we have to take a hard look at
how we are training and empowering
public health workers to act on
situations such that we can get ahead of
them instead of constantly looking
backwards and
leading sort of based on our
retrospective understanding of what's
happening
next slide
i also think in addition to having the
data and having the workforce and you
know obviously we can look at what's
happening in events that are happening
but in the interim we need to practice
we don't need to practice not just as a
workforce
with the plans that we have but also as
societies and i have spent a lot of time
thinking about
how pandemic threats relates to other
hazards in our life and i spent a lot of
time thinking about how it relates to
how we think about fires and what's
clear is that when you have a recurring
hazard
you don't just need the capacities to
deal with them you also need to practice
what you do when it happens and that is
something where i think we are quite
deficient and there are i think more
opportunities to practice
prior to the pandemic we did a study
looking at how
taiwan
conducted every single year mass
vaccination exercises they did it during
the flu season they did it so that they
could boost
uptake of flu vaccines among the most
vulnerable but they also did it so that
they could practice what they would do
in a pandemic so not only could they
test their systems
and their personnel
but that the public would know where to
go to get a vaccine so that in an
emergency it wouldn't feel like this
weird thing that showed up out of
nowhere that it was the thing that you
do just like we do regular fire drills
so that when the alarms go off for real
we don't spend um critical time trying
to convince ourselves it's not really
happening we just act because it feels
familiar we rely on that muscle memory
and i think we need to do more of that
in public health
next slide
and then finally i i talked about this
sustainment issue and the point that we
can't just buy these single-use
solutions every time we have an
emergency we can't just
you know
take a whole lot of money try to hire a
whole lot of contract workers and then
as soon as the case numbers come down
and the funding lapses we let them all
go and then find ourselves scrambling
when the next event happens we have to
sustain it and this is i have data here
from the united states but i think this
is playing out in many many places
across the globe where we have that
initial emergency response and then we
get tired and we move on to other
priorities and so this is just what the
what the what public health preparedness
look like
in uh the early you know 2001 2002 tell
the three so 2001 some of you may be too
too young to remember but the nation
experienced a real shock in terms of the
events of september 11th and a real
commitment to never again make sure that
we are unprepared for public health
emergencies um and so there was a real
increase in the amount of funding and
that was sustained for quite a while and
sort of the peak was around 2005 where i
would say that was probably the time
when our preparedness programs were the
strongest
but then if you go to the next slide
you'll see over time that commitment
lapsed
and these data
cut off before i think the worst of what
we saw happen in public health which was
the um
the economic downturn of 2008 where we
know that there was a hemorrhaging of
staff from health departments as state
budgets
basically contracted and we saw this
play out in other places around the
world as well 2008 represented a real i
think departure point in terms of our
preparedness programs and it was also
accelerated by the fact that national
funding for these programs dried up at
the same time that that the economic
crisis really strained local budgets
next slide
this has consequences this has real
consequences this boom and bust cycle
has real consequences and one of them
was just before the pandemic we
interviewed health departments around
the united states asking them about
their response to the measles outbreak
that were happening before the pandemic
and one of the questions we asked them
about was contact tracing the extent to
which they were employing contact
tracing and responding to these measles
outbreaks if you don't know anything
about measles it is the clearest case
for the need to use contact tracing
measles is a highly transmissible virus
and wanting to put a large circle around
it is is really quite important but what
we found is that most health departments
were not using contact tracing they
didn't have the force to do contact
tracing so when they had measles
outbreaks basically all they were doing
was kind of putting up a notice saying
if you were in these places during these
times you may have been exposed to
measles call your health care provider
great if you tell the healthcare
provider what to say
great if you actually have a healthcare
provider to go to and we certainly know
that both of those situations are not
necessarily true so
we saw a degradation in capacity just
before the pandemic and the consequences
of that were very clear in the pandemic
when we need an emergency supplemental
to suddenly hire all of these contract
workers to do the work of contact
tracing which if you know anything about
contact tracing is more like an art than
a science and really hard to just drop
in place and have it be effective
overnight
next slide
so this is really my last content slide
which is to say despite what you may
have heard last night about the pandemic
be over
i don't think that it is but
even if you think that the emergency of
covid is over even if you think that 500
plus deaths a day is no longer an
emergency i don't but if you do
you should not take from the ending of
kovid that this is a once in a century
crisis and we have 99 more years of
safety the fact is inside you alluded to
this in your opening remarks the
frequency with which we are having these
sorts of events is increasing there will
be more so these investments in
surveillance and workforce and many many
many other components of preparedness
have to be viewed as fixed costs
maintaining an infrastructure that
appropriately addresses the hazards of
our times which is infectious disease
emergencies so with that thank you
[Applause]
any clarifying questions
okay
yeah
i thank you so much for the presentation
i
worked on one of the first federal
vaccination sites in oakland one of
those massive vaccine sites and
we really were building stuff from
scratch
i'm really wondering why are there other
reasons as to why public health
departments are notoriously underfunded
for pandemic operations are they
allocating
budgets to other things
are there other reasons for that
um so quick response uh
so um
what we found we did another study
actually looking at mass vaccination
capabilities at health departments and
one of the things we found is that um
health departments tended to work on
building plans to hand out pills because
they were working around an anthrax
response scenario rather than a
vaccination strategy scenario which is a
very very different one in part because
of not enough resources to do those
sorts of plans but also
they had to do mass vaccination efforts
in some part during the 2009 pandemic
and we
very frequently heard from health
departments
yeah we used to have plans for 2009 but
the person who worked on those plans is
no longer here
so
yeah
why is infectious disease frequency um
increasing outbreaks
yeah i mean it's sort of the conditions
of our times and the globe we are much
more connected than we ever were
we so we do a lot more travel than we
did so that just
gives the ability for people to mix in
ways they didn't mix and to bring things
with them also we are encroaching into
areas
that put us in contact with pathogens
that we may not have had contact with
and you know environmental drivers of
pathogen emergence and spillover is
increasing and then we as a society are
more vulnerable to these things we have
higher levels of chronic illness
you know
vaccine coverage
has has lapsed and so that just makes us
more vulnerable to infectious diseases
in general and so that's why you're
hearing about measles and polio and
things that we didn't have to talk about
you know 20 years ago quite as much
again
thank you
so um
our next speaker
is dr belmont james and
there are a lot of endearing qualities
about him and one being that i just
noticed that he has a stopwatch in his
phone
and i think that's certainly the
academic side of his personality not the
politician side of his personality
because politicians don't know when to
stop speaking it's only the professors
who are timed by other classes lining up
outside so
thanks
thank you very much indeed to
dr assad and for the invitation um from
yale university to speak here today to
tell you the truth um
when i was in the south african
parliament you're given five minutes to
speak
normally that means that they will shut
it down after five minutes is something
called the guillotine which means you
you work on 100 words per minute and you
practice it
so um
with that being said let me
speak about
the subject of vaccines so i can get the
next slide my disclaimer slide
no conflicts of interest and just thanks
to all of those individuals for being of
assistance the next slide please
so there's a colleague there's a growing
consensus in the world that um
we need to do three things we need to
focus on three areas of work
the first
has to do with
training and educating a new generation
of
individuals in public health and
clinical medicine
with high levels of expertise in a
distributed way globally and to network
them the second
is to upscale surveillance and we speak
a lot about real-time surveillance we
actually don't have
global systems of real-time surveillance
this is a 10-year long project
not easy to do and the third is to have
a decentralized system of vaccine
manufacturing
in the world so i'm going to focus on
that
and
as you can see on the screen
there is now a commitment
to developing vaccines within 100 days
which is breathtaking
the the innovation during cover 19 was
breathtaking in terms of the speed of
vaccine production
and using new technology platforms
and after our experience now we need to
capture lessons learned from this
[Music]
period of vaccine development
we need to deliver options for the
expansion of manufacturing capacity and
low and middle income countries
and we need to establish a delivery and
accountability plan those are the three
elements
and i'd like just to share with you some
thoughts about what's happening in
africa
next slide please
so um what the framework is being set
largely through sepi
and it's planned plan
to work towards shortening the time
that it takes to produce vaccines to 100
days and it really is quite
incredible what has happened in the
world of modern science today during
covert 19 this is an effort to even
improve it and they think it's possible
with the right
strategic focus
timing funding and so on
next slide please
so let me just say that and you would
know this so i would just repeat this
vaccines
are among the greatest achievements of
modern health science
it's the most one of the most effective
public health interventions available
and to note for those of you who follow
this
vaccination immunization rates are
falling in many countries
one in five children in africa still do
not receive all of the necessary and
basic vaccines
and as of 2015 africa accounted for 33
of the world cases of vaccine
preventable diseases in children under 5
you can see
the chart on the right hand side
indicating
what
that 33
amounts to
cumulatively
next slide please
just to note that governments in
sub-saharan africa spend on average 73
dollars per capita on health care and
that is less than 2 percent of the per
capita spending by high-income
governments and while below their
national needs
the figure on the right-hand side
provided by the world bank
i'm sorry it's not the best slide but
the bottom line you can see
what the contrast is between
the investment made by government in
sub-saharan africa compared to
high-income countries
and that's per capita that is not a
crude figure
so you can see where the slack lies
presently next slide please
so it is estimated that every one dollar
spent on childhood immunizations in
africa it turns 44 in economic benefits
just looking at the economic benefits
side of it and the four major vaccine
preventable diseases
collectively cost the african region 13
billion each year
so there is the case it saves lives it
extends lives
um
it saves money in terms of the impact
in the longer term it is a completely
worthwhile intervention and investment
from a model point of view from a
life-saving point of view and from an
economic point of view
at the same time africa produces less
than one percent of its vaccine needs
so there's the case to be made it's a
case to be presented to politicians
next slide please
just demographically
2030 africa will have a working
population of a billion people
and secondly a really important point to
emphasize in our my estimation you've
got six months
in fact it's a small window of
opportunity
to introduce whole of government
initiatives to support the establishment
of an integrated competitive and
cohesive vaccine manufacturing market
for the african continent
covered 19 was tragic but covert 19
illustrated the value of investing in
preparedness
including in manufacturing
of vaccines
and this and the picture on the
right-hand side just tells you
what the benefits are in fact
next slide please
so
this
particular illustration tells you what's
going on
in africa presently in terms of
vaccine related activity
the data on the slide is three weeks old
um and i've been updated regularly but
this is a fairly current picture and
there's one update i'd like to share
with you
to note that the who is introduced a
a
mrna vaccine transfer technology hub is
based in south africa
in the city of cape town where i am from
and has identified seven
spokes as sites for vaccine
manufacturing
that is hugely ambitious
we believe that south africa and senegal
presently have the greatest potential
and are focusing on that
so
the countries involved
as targeted entities presently are kenya
rwanda senegal south africa and ghana as
the sites
the second category are all the other
industrial partnerships
let me just say that presently there is
no end-to-end vaccine manufacturing
for human applications in africa at all
presently
what we have is fill and finish
there what there is a history of
end-to-end vaccine manufacturing
starting off with r d and ending up with
a product
for animals but even the under
investment in that
has led to a degradation of that system
largely in south africa in a place
called honest world which is outside of
pretoria when it comes to plants that's
another story for another occasion
so what does emerge are other industrial
partnerships using
uh non-mrna platforms and you can see
what the list looks like there
algeria morocco south africa egypt
nigeria botswana and uganda
and what the listings
of the developments underway
an update is that
aspen pharmacare which is the biggest
pharmaceutical company in on the african
continent
which had a license to fill and finish
jnj
has signed a deal with the serum
institute of india to produce four lines
of vaccines and we don't know what those
lines are we will discover so what you
see is a
a pharmaceutical company partnering up
with the serum institute of india which
of course sees africa as its market and
will cultivate that
and uh oboe is saying that here the
private sector is leading it's not
government that's leading on the
initiatives
i just wanted to point out you see down
the line botswana somebody called
patrick sun shiong
so patek soon chiong is a south african
a physician
he's been in los angeles made an
enormous amount of money
on an ip issue when it came to cancer
and is now one of the wealthiest people
in the u.s he owns the l.a times
and he has decided to invest in vaccine
manufacturing both in botswana as well
as south africa
the botswana operation is
running together with peter hotes and
the baylor college of medicine
and uses non-traditional traditional
means of producing vaccines
so
so the next slide please
this is the amount of money that's
flowing into africa presently it's one
and a half billion euros
with 300 million euros to be raised it's
a lot of money
but on the grander scheme of things is
not that much
to note that the money is philanthropic
the money is bilateral
and the money
is also multilateral
and that africa itself is contributing
very little to that
and to make the sustainable will require
greater commitment a part of african
governments to in fact invest in
vaccine manufacturing
there are major challenges
um
the people are
sort of mesmerized by mrna
there's no way
we can use mrna platforms to produce
vaccines in in africa as a whole it has
to be a combination a smart combination
that focuses on african-specific
diseases both emerging ones and existing
ones
to be sustainable you need to do both
you need to produce
for an african market for routine
immunization as well as pandemic scale
up scale down dynamic response
and getting it done as a business
requires
a whole range of
interventions that would make
the dearest thinking of it possible and
so on so overall saying this is not
straightforward
next slide please
so to meet the public health challenge
countries have organized
on
a national regional and continental
level
uh in africa
they emerged the partnership for african
vaccine manufacturing
which is an initiative of the au
and at the multi lateral and global
level wh vaccine technology transfer
hubs
involve the who and its partners
the next slide please
we set up something called vac task in
response to a request by the south
african government
for a team of us to help them
get in the business of
manufacturing vaccines
so we set up that task it's called it's
an independent advisory body
to governments it's working as a
frontrunner
for the partnership for african vaccine
manufacturing
it's supporting an effort to harmonize
the regulatory environment this is both
product regulation and price regulation
and financial regulation
but in this case um
product regulation by way of the african
medicines agency the 54 countries in
africa if you want to make vaccines and
need
you know approval of all 55
i mean it's a nightmare right so there's
a effort to
have an ama do that this is not going to
be straightforward but we need that
facility
and the purpose of that task just
finally is to accelerate and expand
africa's r d and manufacturing drives
checking on my time
and therapies next slide please
this is who we are it's chaired by
jeremy farat the welcome trust i
co-chair it and you can see it's a very
distinguished list of
individuals being part of that task
next slide please
what we've done to date as we conducted
a first fact-finding mission to south
africa
um and we're currently finalizing a a
report
a set of policy recommendations uh to be
presented to the south african
government we've also hosted virtual
meetings on the latest developments in
pandemic response the next slide please
we are concerned and make
recommendations about four things first
to get procurement right there needs to
be a harmony in procurement internally
you can't have the health department
procure on the basis of price
and you don't talk to trade in
an industry
so there needs to be internal
coordination and then there has to be
continental coordination
secondly the need for human capital
investment in manufacturing
skills that is not the science part
which is
in reasonable shape in south africa
but in good manufacturing practice
those skills are absent you deal with
them by importing those skills
immediately but you need to train
a pipeline of people in that area
third a point i already made about the
regulation the regulated environment
needs to be upgraded in a major scale
and there has to be also r d
infrastructure investment and in
adjacent industries
along the
the value chain as as we move through
the slide on the right hand side um is
just to
illustrate and also to amplify the fact
that the biggest investment that we can
make is in human skill
that's the biggest one and that takes a
while but that's something that's an
important challenge
the next slide please
you can do all of that but if people
if people don't trust vaccines and if
they don't believe that is a good thing
to have it's a kind of pointless
exercise right now africa's sitting with
a surplus of vaccines they don't know
what to do with it
so what's important is to have a model
for vaccine take up and just very
quickly
this is the environment in which you're
operating you can see that when it comes
to trust in science sub-saharan africa
is um is is the lowest and it's
declining
the next slide please when you look at
trust in scientists
you can see the same thing
so also very low
and declining
the next slide please
believe that sources
based corona virus related decisions on
scientific advice by region you can see
the level of distrust in the world
also sub-saharan africa is quite low
but the lowest is russia and the
caucuses in central asia next slide
please
these are the categories of people that
are the most trusted in the world
starting off with doctors and nurses and
ending at the bottom religious leaders
and the next slide please
okay so that's the context in which
we're operating
and so we started a project where we
wanted to interview people who at the
late stage
come for vaccinations to understand
what the
what the barriers were
and this is
unique in a sense the study because
these are late stage wait and see people
who come for vaccination and once you
interview them and we are running the
project in south africa and zimbabwe the
next slide
this is a publication we made the next
slide please
this is to the next slide we just wanted
to
assess what the attitudes are to
vaccine mandates
the next slide please
the key thing there is that there was a
high percentage of individuals who
supported the use of vaccines in
zimbabwe
you had the normal
pattern where high income people
would have the least support and low
income people the most support
and the reason has very little to do
with education or income
but to
how many women in particular
fall into the category of those
who had the most support of vaccine
mandates
and the important thing was and as a
discovery we found if you can show the
next slide please
is that
the individuals
who were key to the answer
around vaccine vaccine acceptance
were mothers of children
even in deep rural zimbabwe we said they
had the most questions about vaccine
safety
you know
actually who tested it where was it
approved and so on and clearly you can
understand it's kind of obvious that
that that's
would be the case so just to say around
drivers of vaccination
the trusted sources of information
ministry of health
your main information methods for them
were traditional media and the most
important influences
had to do with who who it was that loved
them basically those are the ones who
made the real difference in terms of
in terms of
accepting vaccines
next slide i am
10 seconds left i think
these are the main barriers to
vaccination
and as you can see that
more women had major concerns about the
side effects than men
the relationship between wealth and
education
and also
internet use you can see what the story
is there but let me just conclude by
saying for the next slide
that in the case of south africa
what we found is an age grading in terms
of
what
the impact was
of both media
and what
the impact was of the different
influences
and you can see that between 18 and 34
what the differences were
oboe is saying that
the final slide that what the world
needs to do
is develop a model
for successful vaccine
uptake
modulated by region by country and by
culture
to introduce as part of pandemic
preparedness for the next time because
we actually
did not know what we were doing in terms
of driving our vaccination rates
so
um and so that's my concluding note is
that none of this matters unless there
are evidence-based models of vaccine
take-up built into the planning
dna for the next pandemic
and with that thank you very much
if there are any again clarifying
questions here
uh
the
circumstances of very large vaccine
companies are such that
merck for example can take a chance make
coveted vaccines they don't work
they've lost tens of millions of dollars
and they move on
in the face of
the
incipient manufacturers in africa of
which you know i think you've had seven
sites
presumably they don't have the kind of
deep pockets
of a merc
and presumably they're quite vulnerable
to
a particular vaccine they produce and
manufacture
and not having a market and the whole
enterprise could go under
so what is the intent of the global
community to ensure
a reasonable number of purchased
vaccines so that that never happens
so if i may stand it's a wonderful
question if it doesn't quite fit into
the clarifying category
is it okay if i it's the first question
i asked him
after in the panel is that are you
comfortable with that okay thank you
appreciate that okay okay thank you all
right i just want to try to keep
everyone on time thanks
so the next uh speaker is dr beth
cameron
and yeah your presentation thanks
hi everybody i think we go
awesome
well i'm going to be speaking a little
bit about the architecture that we need
and we've heard from both wilmette and
jen about some of the tools that we need
at the national level at the regional
level and the global level i'm going to
talk with i'm going to try to get us up
to the level of talking about the whole
architecture we need for global health
security and pandemic preparedness
i'm going to give you my bottom line up
front
on the first slide which is we need to
be faster
we need to have systems and we need to
practice every time jen alluded to this
when she talked about the firehouse
model
nobody when we think about a hurricane
and hurricane preparedness nobody looks
at a community that is narrowly escaping
a category four hurricane and asks why
did we have so many sandbags or why did
we evacuate in fact everyone's grateful
that nothing happened so we need to get
in the mentality of overacting and that
means we have to have the systems ready
to go and we have to know exactly what
we're doing every time
so next slide please
so i just wanted to start with the
consequences these are the consequences
and i think it's pretty obvious to all
of us who've been experiencing the
pandemic but this slide you know three
years ago when jen wilmette and i were
talking about our last project together
before the pandemic started this was a
pretty
unimaginable
slide next slide
and these were really the consequences
people lost their lives the economy lost
trillions
proliferation of disinformation and
mistrust government struggled
next slide
public health and other governmental
officials and communities hesitated
but there were also a lot of incentives
against
acting fast there were disincentives
for acting fast what i mean by that is
at the national level when you don't
have a system that everybody recognizes
as the way that you're going to spring
into action to respond to a public
health emergency of international
concern you're making a decision on your
own for your own community for your own
government even for your own region
and there are big consequences to
getting it wrong if you don't have trust
that the way that you're going to
respond and act is a certain way every
time next slide
so i'm going to really start by just
defining what i mean by global health
security because the term we use a lot
we also use pandemic preparedness we use
health system strengthening
global health security in my mind is
being prepared to prevent
detect and respond to public health
emergencies that have high consequences
including public health emergencies of
international concern whether they're
naturally occurring
accidentally caused or deliberately cost
so in all of those cases that's health
security it's a piece of the health
system but it's not the only piece next
slide
i think it's important to actually
look at the nesting and it's hard to
tell with the red here these are
interlocking circles and i see health
security and that broader health system
is not in conflict with one another but
sometimes those terms are defined that
way so i wanted to just sort of state my
my view on this topic up front that
preparing for pandemics is a piece of
being prepared for an outbreak that
might happen on a national or regional
basis is a piece of our broader health
system so doctors nurses and access to
care which is absolutely vital for
pandemic preparedness
and it's all a piece of our broader
global health system
so all of this in order to be prepared
for a pandemic we need to have systems
that work at all of these levels next
slide
so this is a slide that i drew from a
document that jen also referenced which
is the global health security index a
project that all three of us have worked
on over the last couple of years this is
a map that just shows preparedness by
country this was put together by the
economist impact by the nuclear threat
initiative by the johns hopkins center
for health security and now the brown
university is part of it too
it looked at over 100 questions all who
member states
and it asked what capacities are there
in place to be prepared to prevent to
detect and respond but it also looked at
other capacities so it looked at things
that were particular to the ability of a
country to be prepared for an outbreak
or a public health emergency like your
laboratory system your public health
workforce your ability to vaccinate your
people
it also looked at things like numbers of
doctors and nurses it looked at trust in
government it looked at trust in science
in the last version
and it looked at a country's ability to
deal with crises in general
next slide
and the bottom line is the average score
taken together across all those
countries was 38.9 out of 100 and that's
just what countries could do that
doesn't necessarily mean that they even
used those capacities this tool was not
intended to be predictive of how
countries could do simply was meant to
look at what countries would be able to
do if they actually mustered the
capacities that they had
next slide
so i want to talk about architecture and
what existed before covid19 in order to
fill those preparedness gaps and be
prepared to respond
in the face of an emerging infectious
disease threat like covid19 so drawing
back um to sars to the stars epidemic in
2003
the international health regulations
which is essentially the agreement that
world health organization member states
have with one another saying that they
all plan to be prepared for a public
health emergency of international
concern were updated
they were updated because the world
recognized into back in 2003 when sars
hit that countries were not prepared to
deal with a public health emergency
and the world gave a deadline of 2012 in
order for all countries to be prepared
in that intervening time what happened
because the ihrs were
good but imperfect in that they didn't
define exactly what countries needed to
do in order to be prepared and when
countries hit the 2012 mark they either
didn't know or they didn't know about
each other's level of preparedness
because there was no publication no
record of how prepared countries
actually were there was no red yellow
green sort of stoplight mechanism so
following 2005 and then into 2012 when
we recognized that most countries
weren't actually going to hit the
deadline that was put into place
the ebola epidemic hit in 2014 and there
was a lot of work already
going on
post-2012 this deadline that everyone
missed
and countries decided they were going to
put in place
a scoring scheme to actually tell
whether or not countries were prepared
themselves and to be able to send people
to each other's borders to actually look
at how prepared they were and the who
joint external evaluation tool was put
into place to do that and you can
actually go online and look at how
prepared countries are at the who
website we used a lot of these questions
and added to those as the basis for the
global health security index which you
can also go online and look at
preparedness for every country
around the same time
many governments over 60 governments
launched something called the global
health security agenda which is a
coalition of countries that decided we
should meet regularly to talk about how
prepared countries are for pandemics
during this period of time this rough
period of time during which h1n1
influenza happened ebola happened sars
happened zika happened countries were
worried about influenza cases h7n9 and
h5n1 which were high consequence but
weren't spreading as an epidemic or a
pandemic
a lot happens budgets actually did
increase for health security
in some spaces but not across our whole
public health preparedness space looking
at jen's i totally agree with her
nonetheless when you look at that
massive level of gap 38.9 out of 100
when you look at the huge swath of work
to be done on things like how do we make
vaccines how do we deliver them how do
we distribute them how do we do a
vaccine update
funding and political will was wholly
insufficient to be prepared and we
didn't have sort of recognized systems
for how we would spring into action or
triggers for those systems to work when
an emerging infectious disease threat
like copen19 came to call next slide
and so what resulted
is that a lot had to be created from
scratch on the fly in 2020 and this is
an example of a lot of great work that
happened during the pandemic but it
wasn't in existence beforehand so as one
key example
the act accelerator the access to cobit
19 tools accelerator was created
in 2020 by governments
by non-governmental organizations by
international organizations like the who
like unicef welcome trust the gates
foundation multiple governments the
global fund against hiv aids tb and
malaria
gabi the vaccine alliance came together
and said
how are we going to get
tools like supplies vaccines tests
therapeutics personal protective
equipment oxygen to countries that don't
have access to these things so that was
created on the fly during the pandemic
and it's a great example of what can be
done there's also a lot
cropping up about how it could or maybe
could be improved
for the next pandemic but this is a big
open question how will it be maintained
which pieces of it will be maintained
what is the best way to keep this work
going and how do we fund that work
regions like the african union and
wilmette talked a lot about some of the
work to manufacture vaccines there's
also an african union platform called
avat that came online in order to
distribute vaccines on the african
continent so regions working with the
global architecture it was bumpy there
wasn't always agreement on how that
would work but these structures
are in existence now and we need to
figure out as a world how best to
maintain and move them forward kovacs
came into play which is the vaccine
platform piece of the act accelerator
the g7 the group the world's largest
economies
the g20 they all raised a lot of money
billions of dollars in order to be able
to fill some of these gaps
finally this year
the world agreed the wato agreed to
waive intellectual property on coven 19
related vaccines
and all of this amount there were
presidential summit and that the u.s
government and others spurred into
action so a lot of work happened but
still we landed in a place where
millions of people died and we didn't
have the systems that we needed so this
is this is the architecture as it exists
and what happens next next slide
is really
a big open question so i'm going to talk
for just a couple more minutes about
where some of this might go and what
recommendations there are some things
that have been done some things that
have not yet been done but i want to
make it really clear to everyone that
this is an open question that still
needs to be shaped with agreement around
the world that's being actively
discussed this week at the un general
assembly next slide
so i highly recommend if you haven't
looked at some of the reports that have
come out i do think
that the international experts that were
commissioned to do a number of reports
that i'll mention did a great job doing
them and there's some really great
executive summaries that i think really
put into you know a lot of converging
recommendations came out of this
pandemic so far
so the g20 high level independent panel
looked primarily at financing
do we have enough money to prepare for
the next pandemic do we have enough
money to be able to respond to the next
pandemic and where is it going to come
from what's the role of multilateral
development banks like the world bank
and also
do we need a new fund for pandemic
preparedness that is one recommendation
that was acted on i'm really happy to
say just a couple of weeks ago the world
bank did launch a new fund for pandemic
preparedness with over 1.4 billion
dollars it's not enough the vision is to
have at least 10 billion dollars a year
for this fund but it is
a big step forward and it is a
recommendation that was shared by a
number of international experts and it's
something that the us government and
other partners around the world really
pushed for
at the same time the independent panel
for pandemic preparedness and response
the ippr under the leadership of ellen
johnson sirleaf the former president of
liberia and helen clark the former prime
minister of new zealand
put out a report that focused a lot on
leadership and governance for the next
pandemic threat they recommended a
global health threats council a set of
world leaders that would meet regularly
on pandemic threats should come together
and that that should have happened you
know in the last year that
recommendation has not yet been acted
upon so it's a piece of the architecture
that is still
out there in question
wilmette alluded to the 100 days mission
this is in effect
a recommendation that came out of the
united kingdom's g7 presidency last year
to be able on a very systematized basis
to look at all emerging potentially
pandemic pathogens and develop platforms
for vaccine candidates so that we can
basically be ready to scale and produce
to do clinical trials and then scale and
produce vaccines for almost any emerging
potential pathogens this is a really
great playbook but it is not yet funded
and there isn't yet a roadmap for how
we're actually going to then produce
those vaccines and i think moment did a
great job of laying out some of the
challenges there
the lancet commission published a large
set of recommendations just last week
some of which converge with these other
documents and some of which are also new
so there's a lot of work that's been
done not all of it's been acted on next
slide
there's also a question about what we're
going to do about accidental and
deliberate biological events
all the technologies that we need to be
able to be prepared for the next
pandemic threat are absolutely vital but
also we run the risk of inadvertently
creating the catastrophe
that we're trying to prevent if that
technology is misused accidentally or on
purpose and so there's a movement to
launch a new organization called the
international biosecurity and biosafety
initiative for science to bring together
funders of research the private sector
and governments in order to tackle this
issue and the nuclear threat initiative
is launching this effort
this fall that's another piece of the
architecture that has not yet been
formed but is starting to to be built
next slide
so
when we look at the diagram on the right
these are my
go-to pieces for the global health
security architecture the pandemic
preparedness architecture that we need
when we look at financing we've made
some strides at preparedness financing
with the launching of the new fund a
couple of weeks ago there's not yet
agreement though on things like how do
we get surge financing into place so
that low-income countries can get in
line to buy vaccines early on in the
next pandemic that's a big open question
that still needs to be resolved in order
to make the manufacturing architecture
that wilmette outlined actually work
country capacity
huge number of gaps in country capacity
but
increasing political will and interest
and probably a window with coven 19 and
now monkey pox to maintain interest at
the highest levels of government in
actually filling those gaps
that's critical that these two things
are related to one another that donors
that this new fund and that countries
look at their massive number of gaps in
many cases including in our own country
and prioritize which gaps to fill and
and how that will actually make them
more prepared so there's technical work
but also political work that needs to be
done here
on access to medical counter measures in
a crisis a lot happened that's really
covered 19 specific with the act
accelerator being created with kovacs
being created with regional
organizations like avat being created
but none of that has been agreed on or
concretized for other emerging pandemic
threats that's another big open question
on political will there has not been
agreement to create a new structure like
a global health threats council in the
absence of that there are questions
about who will ring the alarm bell at
the highest levels in the next 2020
scenario that we face
and then finally accountability so there
has been a movement one that the u.s
government has supported among others to
amend the international health
regulations to make them sharper to make
the reporting requirements more specific
and there's also an active negotiation
in geneva around the need for a pandemic
instrument or treaty to bring some of
this together
and sort of you know
glue it
next slide
so i'm just going to leave you with this
and what this is supposed to represent
is that we have all the ingredients that
we need
maybe the only good thing that's come
out of this pandemic is we now have all
the tools we have the ingredients we
have the thought leadership that we need
in order to make the systems that are
prepared that will make us prepared for
anything that comes our way but now we
really need the recipes and the practice
so that the next time we actually are
prepared we can actually
bake whatever it is that you want to
bake that would taste the best to you
we need to be prepared to do it every
single time using the tools that we now
have i'll stop there
any clarifying questions
from beth initially
are you stretching or raising your hand
okay
just checking
all right so we can go to the panel now
so we'll come as promised we'll come to
dr sten berman's uh question
um and that will be
your questions if you remember you can
start and we can or we can ask that or
to rephrase office well to say that's a
great question
so you know vaccines are all about
volume
and um
the african market is one market
and most companies would
have to look at the bigger picture in
terms of
providing it that's the first point the
second is that packings are made by
industry
they're made by companies
they're not made by governments
and therefore there has to be
collaboration with industry on this
effort
and so government's role is to enable
third is
is the point i made before it has to be
a combination a smart combination of
routine
immunization
manufacturing and supply
together with the ability to scale up
and scale down and they mean so
i'm making very general points but
that's required and for it to be
sustainable
uh beyond the initial investments
uh african governments would have to put
somebody on the table
for this issue and that's going to take
some political work
okay
there's there's really not yet a roadmap
for when you look at something like the
100 days mission which is incredibly
ambitious the ability to make a vaccine
for any potentially pandemic threat
within 100 days and then what people
colloquially call the 200-day mission
which is then the ability to scale that
up and then produce it and distribute it
when you take that complexity and then
look at a continent like africa as a
plan for vaccine manufacturing and you
think where should different platforms
be produced how can that couple with
routine immunizations so that vaccines
will actually be purchased and procured
it's complex and i think it's so complex
that some people are just sort of frozen
and what we need to do is actually start
putting road maps out there putting
ideas on the table for how this
architecture can be maintained
do you agree with that i do agree with
that but also to say that right now the
corporate sector is leading the effort
so on the african continent aspen farmer
care is the biggest company
so it has corporate interests and
there is a need to deal risk
when it comes to
sort of local manufacturing sites
uh so
and so we have to make sure that we have
a proper private partnership with proper
agreements around
uh benefit sharing built into it
so i think one another thing if i may
add
and first disclaimer i sit on the gabi
board
but this is my personal opinion
uh which is that one of javi's the
global which was formerly called gabi
the vaccine it's formed now called the
vaccine alliance it was called global
alliance for vaccines and immunizations
um
one of the mandates one of the reasons
why countries put money into that entity
is
its market shaping role
if there ever were
any
case for
gavi flexing its muscle
is to shape the market um in sub-saharan
actually africa not just sub-saharan
africa continent-wide
um market shaping
in favor of
sustaining manufacturing having said
that
um
it in order for
um for for for the capacity to survive
it will have to be an uh a market-based
solution
some players in that ecosystem
that's the very nature of markets
we have tried
government
led manufacturing around the world it
rarely works there are exceptions
uh but it rarely works
truly wholly nationalized
vaccine manufacturing system so on the
one hand i think gavi has a role to play
in this on the other hand it is through
sort of nudging markets shaping markets
not uh sort of encouraging hundred
percent nationalized manufacturing
so i'll come to sorry you were going to
say this no just to say which means you
might get proclaimed right yeah
absolutely that's market shipping
essentially yeah um and so a couple of
questions and i'll have uh
two versions of the same question uh
from both of you for
jennifer and beth
so jennifer i'll start with you what are
two mistakes u.s policymakers made in
this um
pandemic
just two as well
top two
um let me see how i can lump it
it's a big enough bin to catch a lot of
stuff i mean i think beth hit on it in
terms of that acting fast um and then
acting
um
given the possibility of the worst case
scenario and um
you know we
saw um quite
this actually happened in covet and it
happened in monkey fox same thing
one was you know testing was our
critical failure and the first one was
marred by the rollout of testing in
covid was marred by technical
difficulties
but there was a period of time there
where we didn't act on the urgency we
didn't think this could get really bad
and how can we scale to how badly it can
be that we saw that play out in covid uh
sorry in monkey box where um you know we
had the tests already rolled out we
didn't have to overcome that technical
hurdle that was already there
but that infrastructure was really
scaled to a much smaller event it wasn't
looking ahead to
a more distributed community-wide event
whereby you would need to have this
testing more distributed so i think that
was the first one was was what beth said
sort of failure to kind of think ahead
how bad could this be and what do we
need to start putting into place now
given the possibility of where this
could go
i think the other thing
was that we really need to
take a hard look at our health system
and make sure our responses are
integrated into our health system
because that really is the first point
of contact um but also um you know i
think we need to take a look at the
how equipped our health systems are for
these these events
and really perhaps rethink healthcare
models this just-in-time you know very
lean organizations just don't work when
there's an emergency and unfortunately
there's lots of emergencies it's not
just coving i mean i was telling a group
of students earlier we did a study just
before the pandemic looking at hospitals
in new york city and how ready they were
for the 2017 flu season which rivaled
the 20 2009 pandemic in terms of volume
and they really really struggled then
and that was i think uh an omen for how
difficult things would be at covent yeah
absolutely right so building capacity of
both of you for actually all three of
you alluded to
after an emergency is like you know
recruiting firefighters
after you know your house starts burning
and so so you don't call them uh at that
time
so so i'll
ask you beth um
what do you think are the two biggest
mistakes that global policymakers made
yeah well i'll just say in 2020 i think
i'll just stand that
the u.s government was exiting the world
health organization the global stage
around the time that the world in my
opinion needed us leadership
the most and so i think that was a huge
mistake i think that dogged the response
for months and months and months
and probably still
makes it harder
for us when we are looking at how best
to fix some of these architectural
questions that i just put up on the
screen so that's number one i think
we
you can be
frustrated with the global system you
can be rightly asking for the global
system to do more
you can look at the united nations and
say i wanted i want you to do better
but leaving
exiting only hurts people including
people in your own country so i think
that was a huge
a huge mistake
the second thing i'll say and maybe i'll
just bring the question up to the level
of you know what do we
what do we as policy makers in the
united states globally fail to do in
every emerging infectious disease crisis
that i've been a part of and i'll
include myself in this
i think that we fail to look at the
worst case scenario
and plan for and plan backwards from
that that doesn't mean that we act
without any evidence or we put in place
things that are factually incorrect
but it does mean that we need tools back
to some of the things that jennifer said
in her talk we do need tools that are
ready
in the absence of information in the
absence of perfect evidence and in the
face of the uncertainty that we will
always face at the beginning of a public
health crisis and so we need to be
prepared for the absolute worst thing
that can happen for the multiple worst
case scenarios not just the thing that
we think most likely will happen i'll
just say i think public health in
general public health officials have so
little resources they're trained to be
able to and want to respond to the thing
that's most likely because that's all
they can do we have to resource public
health appropriately and train the next
generation of public health leaders to
be thinking about decisions for the
worst case scenarios and that time that
we lose in that preparing sets us back
and puts us behind the curve every time
i agree so i couldn't agree more i think
it wasn't uh technology that failed us
so pcr
was a technology that has been with with
us for for decades uh testing uh and
masks you know masks i'm wearing you
know this technology is pretty
straightforward and it was designed
actually even the best version of it was
designed in 2009-2010
etc it was governance
and and if we don't have the capacity to
make effective decisions
i think we will continue to see
these kinds of things so i'll open up
right here so i just wanted to add one
of the things that i think one of the
faders is we stumbled on the risk
communication
um and
uh that's partly because
part of it's the difficulty of a moving
target you know
um but there were some basic principles
around risk communication that when
simply not followed by many countries in
the world
instance you know inconsistent
communication changed the people
speaking
um and and we stumbled in many respects
and so the public was
also to face this information and
misinformation we understand that but in
the middle of that
i think strategies for better as
communication that really develops for
well you're speaking to the choir
because some of us were jumping up and
down
in february and march uh we did our here
at yale we did our first national survey
on february 9
2000
looking at the the behavioral and
communications response looked at what
were the sources of um
of information that were trusted etc and
what what should be the response before
it was named covet we did our first
national survey around vaccines on may
9th um
2020. and so you're absolutely right and
and we thought as a global community
that we need to bring the best science
and this is mainstream thinking
forward and we need to insist on the
rigor
of vaccine development science
but not the rigor on vaccine
communication science and that was you
know a very sensible folks thought that
it was just furrowing your brow and
speaking on the instead of prime time tv
was sufficient
and that there were no principles no no
no evidence to to be
um utilized in terms of how to
effectively communicate so you're
absolutely right and next time we better
not do that uh but monkeybox is not a
good
uh you know sign
for that uh you know so i don't you know
i'm i'm not that optimistic
that this will not happen again
i think it's not
it's up to the next uh generation of
public health leaders and scholars and
and um
implementers and policy developers to
make sure that this is not an
afterthought i think we also need people
who are training in public health and
people are training in basic science to
be crosstrained even more effectively
and what i mean by that is that we were
developing new vaccine platforms that
had never been used before mrna vaccine
platforms while we were trying to
communicate to the public about how they
should trust these vaccines and so the
scientific development was amazing and
revolutionary
but that set us back even further with
the trust and science communication
because we were not just talking about
tools people were already nervous about
some segments of society we were talking
about brand new tools that hadn't
actually been tested before so i think
figuring out how to have that kind of
communication with the public around a
new and uncertain science makes it even
more complicated that's absolutely true
so we'll jump to questions from from um
from participants and audience but we'll
go to online questions uh first so maybe
yes
so
i have uh two questions i think this
might be for wilmot uh related to
vaccine manufacturing you know seven
countries that were kind of identified
or so what was the
why were they chosen so that's maybe
question one
the second question is for those
countries
are there plans for skill building to
ensure sufficient human resources as
well
excellent question so the choice of
countries
um
when it came to developing
the spokes
for the mrna transfer technology
was a selection made by the who
and that had to do with whether there
was a existing partners in those
countries
on the areas aspects so tunisia for
example is very well positioned on the
bioinformatics side
but it lacks others and so on so that
was one set of criteria
the other had to do with what companies
chose so you know
so companies chose
to cite work in kenya which makes a lot
of sense kenya has a lot of interest
and experience in developing axi
animal vaccines because of the animal
health experience
south africa probably has the longest
reach so part of it's
just company choices
and so
um and so it's a combination of those
things
any other question from
sure
second question can you say the name of
who's asking sure and this uh
uh jennifer this question comes from dr
christina tower slagle who you met
earlier today
um she was appreciative of your note uh
when you when you noted that
one thing you would invest in was
community health workers so can you
expound on that a little bit more uh why
and how you feel that would help prepare
uh
yeah i mean i think the community health
workers have the potential to touch on
many areas that we saw deficiencies in
one is clearly on health services and
reaching people and continuing to
provide
not just care for the pandemic specific
care
but also all the other care that has to
happen
during a pandemic that doesn't stop and
i think
we cannot put blinders on and only focus
on you know a virus and not consider the
whole health needs of communities and
that's i think a lesson that we
learn every time there's an emergency so
community health workers i think are
important for supplementing the care and
extending care and providing care where
communities are
but they also potentially help on the
risk communication side and um you know
i think that was clearly something that
we had a hard time doing
uh we didn't really have plans for um as
you know beth and wilma and zod said
talking about uh you know we were great
on the technology but we didn't think
about how we were going to roll it out
and get people to want to take it i will
just tell you anecdotally in the last
two years i have talked to hundreds and
hundreds of people about covid vaccines
and one of the
key commonalities that i have found in
those conversations when people are
asking me questions
and they sort of suggest that you know
trust not sure who to trust may be an
issue they commonly don't have a health
care provider in their lives and so
making sure we have people who are in
people's lives not just suddenly they
show up in the midst of a pandemic but
they're in people's lives day to day
dealing with the various medical issues
that could arise throughout someone's
lifespan
then to also be able to broker
conversations about vaccines to be able
to connect people to the services they
need and to be able to get connected you
know that that sort of bottom-up
approach i think is really important so
absolutely and even in your work
uh you talked about billboard that um
healthcare providers were the most
trusted uh source of vaccine information
we've been finding and it's a lot of
those um work for the last 22 years
consistently shows irrespective of
geography
the top most trusted source of vaccine
information is a healthcare provider and
so that means
access to a healthcare provider but also
and again one of the most
lost opportunity in this country
was and beyond uh frankly as well was a
lack of a national cme program to train
healthcare providers
on evidence-based communications methods
and it exists so at yale we created a
cme it's the most subscribed cme program
and the second most uh was a third of
the sub you know of attendance where
people took it for certification and
that was states mandatory
you know cme and so so there is a demand
out there but but you were saying
something else i guess as well no i was
going to say this enormous variation so
it's the healthcare workers and
obviously come first as a category
but the most trusted institution in
tunisia is the military
the master institution of the congo is a
catholic church
and the most trusted institution in
south africa is the president of south
africa it's enormous variation about how
trust works
uh also just to quickly answer the
second part of that question that i
failed to answer
is that
when it comes to vaccine manufacturing
it's you talking about the ecosystem you
build around that including relations
with universities where most of your
scientists are located
and then as i've pointed out where the
gap is the training
in good manufacturing practice in making
vaccines this is the farmer's side on
the pharmacological side eso the gap is
and to
what's requires a fund a scholarships
fund to train people in that area
that takes a little while so in the
meantime there's a need for you to
import skills
so so uh beth i'll ask the next question
from you um
so when you talk to
uh folks and public health leaders
specifically around the world
especially in low middle income
countries not everyone
is on board with the term biosecurity
and biopreparedness um
and and even you know where whatever
version of the word security is
so you sometimes get pushback from there
so any other thoughts on framing
our collective preparedness uh in those
terms
yeah and i think one thing i'll say is
that it depends on who you talk to so if
you're talking to public health
officials sometimes there is concern
with using that term if you're talking
to leaders in ministries of foreign
affairs or in national governments at
the highest levels there's less concern
and that again that's a broad
generalization and it really depends on
the country that you're in and the
people that you're talking to
so i always start by defining what i
mean by health security because it makes
it clear that i'm talking not only about
security but as in national security or
national defense i'm talking about
security for people
our public security and our public
safety so i i like the term health
security i think that it's an important
term i think that we should continue to
use it but i think it has to be framed
in the context of the broader health
system and i think that you just made an
outstanding point in the conversation
about health care workers and community
health
if we don't actually have a strong
health care system we know that we're
not going to have global health security
so you have to look at those two things
together but i do think that there is a
touchiness um amongst
some in the health community to use in
security terminology one challenge i
find with that wherever you sit on that
debate
is that when we have a crisis like covet
19 pretty quickly things move from the
histories of health as spokespeople up
to the level of government and that's
always going to happen you're going to
have prime ministers and presidents
speaking you're going to have ministries
of foreign affairs involved and so you
have to recognize that security is part
of the equation it is it absolutely is
and so the question is how do we work
together to solve this challenge as a
public health and a national
international security issue because it
is and i think copen19 clearly showed
that and so that is another reason why
i'm really in favor of cross-training
people who go into political sciences
and end up in pandemic preparedness and
people who go into public health and end
up in pandemic preparedness so they
don't meet for the first time in the
situation room at the white house and
maybe can i just add to that because um
i heard there was a debate at one point
and particularly when we looked at the
rollout of vaccines globally and the
stark disparities that we saw there was
this kind of rising debate that this was
as a result of our securitization of our
health threat the idea being that
um countries
wanting to preserve their own security
were therefore hoarding vaccines and not
giving it to others and that had we not
kind of viewed the crisis through the
security lens that perhaps that wouldn't
exist
um i will tell you from working in this
field for more than 20 years i kind of
fundamentally reject that interpretation
because let me tell you the hoarding has
persisted long before we ever started
using the word health security we saw it
happen exactly in 2009 before that was
really
a term that was thrown around countries
in emergencies particularly when they're
unprepared and for and and particularly
when we don't have global
mechanisms for sharing we'll do just
what we saw them do and every single
tabletop exercise we've been in with
leaders they tend to have that tendency
so i don't think it's the securitization
i think it is the false understanding of
what it means to be secure
and being secure means
not just
looking inward but also seeing how
events that happen outside um affect
what happens in work
so i'll take the next uh few questions
towards the end of this yeah one little
point it's just there are lots of ebola
samples that are unaccounted for
so the question of laboratory
biosecurity and the transportation of
pathogens security is of the greatest
importance and we need to upscale it
that's all i'll say to those who talk
about
biosecurity not be an important
component
of our own effort
remember all the disaster movies start
with a scientist warning about exactly
lots of
you can make
agents from scratch and there's very
little regulation around the world
that's true this topic and so given that
anyone who goes to public health needs
to be thinking about
diseases that are propagated
intentionally or accidentally that
doesn't mean conspiracy theory it means
this is the fact that you have to deal
with and that means public health and
security have to work together you will
work with the security community if
you're not already and so getting
comfortable with that is important yeah
so maddie thank you
hi i'm ben this question is for you i'm
wondering if um you have in mind um
a country or an entity that has
really put together the architecture and
the pieces that you're talking about
what what is a model or a model that we
could work toward
are there any
it's a great question i think
a couple of i should answer that
question i don't have one country the
model that i that i think fundamentally
will work has to rely on countries being
prepared so filling their filling the
priority gaps that they've identified
through an evaluation that either
they've done or an external organization
has done at the next layer we need to
have strong regional institutions i
think the african union is a great
example of a regional institution that
flexed in a crisis where they weren't
able to get access they were able to
build internal tools for a continent of
over 50 countries
that kind of regional strength is
important because not every country is
going to be able to have everything at
the global level we have to have
institutions that can
develop help develop and invest in
vaccines deliver tests and treatments to
those that can't get them so it it has
to be in all three levels i don't think
any one country can do it
i do think that there are some countries
when you look at just how well they work
internally across
sectors that are doing a great job one
of the reasons that the global health
security agenda was launched
with a number of countries including
finland in 2014 is because at the time
and i believe this is still true the
government of finland had a very strong
interagency mentality where the
ministries of health defense foreign
affairs and agriculture work really
closely together i think that is a model
that we need in order to be prepared for
any kind of health threat within
individual governments it's also true
for the us government i know it's not
easy to see from the outside but there
is constant communication we just have a
slightly bigger
system to hurt the cats
so my laptop so
let's just add one thing we need much
better leadership on this issue
the leaders are elected so you get what
you get and there's no
buy you know resume to evaluate
but you need below
presidents
you need a very strong cater of public
health professionals it provides
stability in terms of leadership on a
civil service
okay so one last question from you i'm
just curious to see like um what growth
can be uh wealthy and uh
research granted universities such as
yale and brown
play on the global stage for endemic
preparedness
so that's a perfect question for you
yeah
i think a few roles um and they're what
universities do we conduct research we
try to gather the evidence
to answer the most pressing questions
we also educate we train the next
generation of leaders to make sure that
we have in place
exactly what wilman talks about
and then one thing that i think has
coped has i think changed how
universities operate and i hope that
this is a legacy of covent which is that
um
we have to do more translational work we
have to do more work to take the
evidence and make sure it gets to the
people who are making decisions and
continue to push on them to make the
right decisions based on the evidence
that piece
you know i think there will always be
room for
independent credible voices to both
evaluate what governments are saying as
well as continue to
educate not just people in our programs
but the general public for how they can
protect themselves and so i think that
translational piece will be
hopefully a bigger
piece of the portfolio of what uh
universities do
yeah no i think that's a
that's a good uh place to end uh i i
resisted rephrasing that question as
what can brown do for you
thank you um
all for being here for your insightful
responses and thank you for for you all
for being here and for your questions
both uh um you know within this from
within this room and and online so
with that
we end this panel thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
you